-President Trump
did an interview today
where he desperately tried
to rebut allegations
that he broke
campaign finance laws.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's easy to grow numb
to all the chaos
surrounding President Trump.
He has a way
of wearing you down,
like the guy
in a romantic comedy
who keeps pushing and pushing
until, finally,
he's standing
outside your house,
trenchcoated with a boom box,
and you think,
"Yeah, I mean,
I guess this is normal."
But yesterday was a truly
remarkable day in politics.
The President's ex-fixer
Michael Cohen
was sentenced
to three years in prison
for committing crimes
he says the President
told him to commit.
And Cohen was clear
that he now considers himself
free to tell the full story
of what Trump did.
-Michael Cohen said today,
"I take full responsibility
for each act
that I pled guilty to.
The personal ones to me
and those involving
the President of
the United States of America."
-He said exactly that, today,
no matter what sentence he got,
would be a day of freedom,
because he was no longer in
the personal and mental prison
that he was in
working for Donald Trump.
-Wow. You know
you're hard to work for
when going to prison
is a relief.
[ Laughter ]
If Andy Dufresne
had worked for Trump,
he would have pulled
a reverse Shawshank
and tunneled back into his cell.
[ Laughter ]
But it really --
[ Applause ]
It really is
a little bittersweet.
This is an incredible
fall from grace for these two.
It was only a few years ago
that Trump
was a reality-TV star,
a New York City blowhard
who would occasionally
flirt with running for president
just for the attention.
And Cohen was right by his side,
enjoying the limelight.
He was the Ed McMahon
to Trump's Johnny Carson,
the Dean Martin
to Trump's Jerry Lewis,
the Salacious Crumb
to Trump's Jabba the Hutt.
[ Laughter ]
In fact,
here's an interview from 2011
where Cohen clearly enjoys
being Trump's right-hand man
and bragging about all
the attention Trump was getting.
Although he used an unfortunate
and prescient analogy
to describe Trump's
political influence.
-We're pleased to be joined
by Michael Cohen,
who's a top lawyer
and right-hand man
for Donald Trump.
And, Michael, the big question
I got on Twitter,
a lot of people want know,
what is Donald Trump up to?
Is he running,
is he not running?
Is he gonna play king-maker?
Is he gonna endorse?
What is the Trump game plan
when it comes to 2012?
-Well, first of all, hi, Rick.
Hi, Amy.
How are you?
Good to see you again.
Donald Trump
is definitely a playmaker.
I actually
used a statement yesterday --
he is now
the godfather of politics.
-I'm sorry.
It sounds great,
but Trump is not
the godfather of politics.
If he were the godfather,
he'd be much better
at getting away
with the stuff he's been doing.
[ Laughter ]
He's more like
the naked drunk dude
running down the street on an
episode of "Cops" of politics.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Today, Trump did
an interview with Fox News,
where he furiously denied
the allegations.
Now, prosecutors and Cohen
are alleging that Trump
used "The National Enquirer"
to cover up an affair
by getting them to pay
for the rights of the story
and then burying it.
Late today, NBC News reported
that Trump was in the room
during the hush-money
discussions
with the tabloid publisher.
Trump was asked about that
and claimed it didn't happen,
but he didn't seem
100% sure about it.
-"The New York Times" is saying
that a tabloid publisher's deal
to hush money is now
endangering Trump even more.
I'm paraphrasing a little bit.
You know, as you look at this,
what do you want
the nation to know about
your former attorney being
sentenced yesterday?
-Well, let me just tell you
about the tabloid.
I don't think --
and I have to go check --
I don't think they even paid
any money to that tabloid.
-I love how he says
he'd have to check.
[ Laughter ]
That makes it sound like
he has a ledger somewhere
listing all of his
illegal payments.
"Let's see, Mafia, Mafia,
not Putin, Mafia...
I got nothin'.
I don't see anything about
a hush payment to a porn star --
Oh, wait!
Yep, never mind.
It says right here,
'fun stuff.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It was the fun stuff.
It was fun.
We had fun."
[ Laughter ]
Trump also keeps insisting that
the payments were totally legal
and did not violate
campaign finance law
despite the fact the prosecutors
in his own Justice Department
and independent legal experts
say they did.
And to prove it,
he brought along some printouts.
-And then you have the other
situation, and every lawyer --
Look -- "Trump didn't violate
campaign finance laws,
and neither did the President."
These people writing stories
that Trump did nothing wrong.
-Oh [bleep] somebody taught
grandpa how to print.
[ Laughter ]
"Grandpa, what are you doing?"
"I'm printing!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Printing.
I like to read my Facebook
in bed."
[ Laughter ]
Fundamentally, for Trump,
this all comes down
to his relationship with Cohen,
who prosecutors say
was the key figure
in a criminal scheme to defraud
the American people.
Trump was asked
why he had hired a guy
he now says is a criminal
and a liar,
and he basically shrugged.
-This was someone who
surreptitiously recorded you.
-Terrible.
-Is now known
as a criminal liar.
Yet this was someone
who was in your inner circle.
-Yeah.
Well, it happens.
I mean, look, it happens.
-No.
It doesn't just happen.
It only happens to you.
No one else accidentally
hires a criminal liar
who pays hush money
to cover up an affair.
Trump's like a guy who
accidentally admits to something
super embarrassing,
thinking it happens to everyone,
and then tries to cover it up.
"One time, you know,
I did that thing
where I got drunk at karaoke,
vomited,
slipped on my own vomit,
and then my pants split open
in front of them all.
We've all done it, right?"
[ Laughter ]
"Who hasn't been there, right?
Slipped on vomit,
butt open.
Co-workers there.
You've been there.
You're shaking your head no.
Okay."
So, today, Trump decided to go
on offense with a TV interview,
but what was he doing yesterday?
Well, his ex-fixer
and one-time friend
was in federal court,
saying the president
directed him to commit a crime.
Trump is doing what you'd expect
the most powerful man
in the world to be doing --
blowing off work
and watching TV.
-I have to say,
we just checked.
The President
isn't in the West Wing yet.
There's no Marine guard outside.
So, he's had all morning
to watch TV
and watch these unfolding
developments in the residence.
-The President has moved from
the residence to the West Wing.
He arrived here at about noon.
-That's right.
Trump was watching TV
all morning and didn't get
into work until noon.
It's like when you know
you're about to get fired,
so you stop caring
if you're bad at your job.
[ Laughter ]
Soon, Mike Pence
is gonna catch Trump
smoking weed out back
by the dumpster.
"Hey, Donald, buddy,
you're still on the clock."
"Whatever, man.
I'm moving to California
and opening a dispensary."
[ Laughter ]
But you can't blame Trump for
wanting to hide this one out.
Every day,
as his legal problems grow,
Trump is freaking out
because Democrats
are about to take control
of the House.
Trump has enjoyed two years
of total Republican control
of the government.
So this is the first time
he's seeing
what real opposition is like.
It's like he's been playing
tee-ball this whole time,
and now he has
to face Randy Johnson.
Although, in reality,
Trump isn't
batting against Randy Johnson.
he's just the bird flying by.
I know, I know, I know
that's from 2001,
but I didn't have a show then.
[ Laughter ]
And the bird's fine.
The bird --
They live together now.
[ Laughter ]
Randy just chucks seeds.
Oh, he's a lefty.
In fact, Republicans
are so scared of Democrats
having power in Congress,
when they met
in the Oval Office on Tuesday,
Vice President Mike Pence
just went totally silent.
In fact,
even after that meeting,
Pence was supposed
to meet with Republicans
but was mostly quiet.
According to
"The Wall Street Journal,"
"Pence, who looked on silently
during the public portion
of the Oval Office discussion,
later met
with Senate Republicans
at their weekly lunch Tuesday
but said little."
I think I know
what's going on here.
Pence wants to be President,
but doesn't want to associate
himself with any of this mess,
so he's just hunkered down,
waiting for Trump to resign.
Look at his body language
in that meeting.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I do when the guy
next to me on the subway
is loudly watching porn
on his phone.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like Pence is trying
to go full chameleon.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is facing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump right now is facing
actual opposition from Congress
for the first time
in his presidency,
and he's clearly rattled.
Every day,
his legal problems get worse.
If the feds ever knock on his
door and ask him, point blank,
if he committed a crime,
he'd probably say...
-I have to go check.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]